9e victoire de la musique ce soir sur
france 2 animée par christian morin et
nagui ingrédients d'un bon spectacle
l'émotion frissons et chansons les élus
du premier tour vous le connaissez tous
ou presque tous ce n'est pas un hasard
la qualité traverse les années sans une
ride
parmi eux alain souchon élus dans la
catégorie meilleur interprète masculin
de l'année chanson de l'année album de
l'année et clip de l'année à
l'instruction vous êtes en direct du
palais des congrès votre coeur va battre
très fort à quatre reprises cinq
reprises oui oui
le hasard a fait comme ça oui et il va
battre encore plus fort quand vous
entendrez peut-être votre nom comme
l'élu des élus maintenant on va écouter
je ne sais pas je trouve que le prix le
plus beau c'est le meilleur album pour
moi alors je ne sais pas puisque je suis
proposé plusieurs fois si je devais
choisir je choisirais album et puis de
toute façon même si je ne gagne pas
assez
je trouve que c'est pas déshonorant
d'être battu par julien clerc ou dit
mitchell ou johnny hallyday puisque
c'est avec je suis encore petit alors
justement vous qui avez souvent dans vos
chansons qu'on aime ici un regard
détaché sur le monde sur les modes
je pense à foule sentimentale comment
vivez-vous ce qui est considéré comme
une compétition qu'on le veuille ou pas
je trouve que c'est un show télévisé qui
est avec un jeu mais c'est pas une
mesure de talent je ne crois pas je
crois que c'est une petite mesure de
popularité puis surtout un jeu on
s'amuse à voter dans le milieu du show
business et puis voilà ça tombe mais ce
n'est pas une vraie mesure de talent
donc vous ne compte pas je suis je gagne
par exemple et que ce ne sera donc pas
johnny hallyday mais johnny hallyday
marquera certainement beaucoup plus son
époque que moi vous voyez c'est pas une
mesure c'est un petit moment comme ça
donc je vous allez le vivre comme vous
chanter vos chansons d'une façon aussi
détaché mais je chante pas de vincent
détachait à non mais ce mode est à ce
titre est un bon mot pour moi une
certaine distance comme un bas il faut
toujours avoir du recul un peu surtout
regarder avec le métier de vous faites
est ce que vous venez de raconter aux
gens fous un peu de recul
absolument muriel robin s'est mise en
colère à l'instruction parce que elle
regrette que barbara est le seul n'est
pas droit à un hommage est ce que c'est
aussi votre avis
j'ai pas réfléchi aux truites mais en
effet je vois pas pourquoi elle serait
en compétition elle est en compétition
avec oui c'est elle devrait avoir un
hommage ou et bien sûr vous et vous vous
allez rendre hommage à un grand un très
grand de la chanson léo ferré oui
qu'est-ce que vous allez chanter ce soir
je vais on va en ai plusieurs
et moi je vais chanter un extrait d'une
chanson magnifique qui s'appelle 20 ans
mais juste un extrait merci alain
souchon et bonne soirée avec nous sur
france 2 merci vous versiez